ANIL SAGAR: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
I'm super excited today to talk
about how traditional companies
across the world are becoming
technology companies using
APIs, delivering
connected experiences,
and accelerating their business.
Myself, Anil Sager, sales
engineer from Google,
part of Apigee team.
Apigee is the intelligent
API management platform
from Google.
Traditional companies becoming
technology companies, just
like Google, how?
How are they doing it?
APIs.
Who are these companies
becoming technology companies
from the traditional world?
These companies are
across the industries,
a traditional bank is becoming
a technology company, a brick
and mortar retail
store that you see
in the street is becoming an
e-commerce technology company.
And an insurance company is
becoming a technology company.
These are the few customers who
use Apigee platform to deliver
data on services, APIs,
securely to their partners,
to their internal applications,
to the new kind of devices
that media is talking about.
We are working with
these companies
from last few years,
precisely 14 years.
We learned a lot
about API management
working with these companies.
We built full API
lifecycle capabilities.
API management is not
about API Gateway.
API management is about how you
solve your business problems.
Today, how many of you
use Google Maps app?
Almost every one of us use
Google Maps app, right?
But how does Google
Maps make money?
Anybody thought?
APIs.
Just like Google Maps
is exposing these APIs
that is consumed by
Go-Jek, Uber, Grab,
the companies, the
traditional companies
are exposing their data
and [INAUDIBLE] as an APIs
and finding new business
revenue channels.
The capabilities that we built
is uploaded by the analysts.
Recently, Gartner positioned
Apigee as a leader
in the API management space.
Just not the leader.
We are the absolute leader,
highest in terms of execution.
Fathers in terms of vision.
What is the big deal?
Why are these
companies using Apigee?
Why are analysts rating
Apigee on top of the charts?
Because APIs will drive
the evolution of business.
It's not about integration.
It's about taking your
business to the new front.
Media is talking
about Vision API.
Media is talking about
the MLs and APIs.
Similar way, how can you
take your data and services
and integrate with
the Google Home,
other businesses?
[? VCT ?] patrons, when it comes
to this business evolution, how
these companies are using
APIs to transform the way
they do business.
The first patron is
about IT modernization
and digital transformation.
You're using machine learning.
You're using Google Dialogflow.
But how can you
connect to your data
on systems so that tomorrow,
can you talk to your bank
and do a transaction instead
of using a mobile app?
Can you talk to Google Home
that talks to your insurance
company?
Can you able to
renew your insurance?
Can you talk to Google
Home and order the product
on your e-commerce tour?
The second patron that we see is
increasing digital connections
and expanding
enterprise boundaries.
Can your company go and
talk to cross industries?
Today you're a bank.
You want to go partner
with e-commerce players.
with insurance players.
How can you do that?
How can you export your
services to these players?
And finally, creating ecosystems
and joining ecosystems.
Creating an ecosystem
is always harder.
It's not easy to
get the developer
base to use your APIs.
Can you go and participate
in other ecosystem?
Can you expose your data
and services as an APIs?
Let's see real world examples.
How these patterns are used
by companies across the world.
PWC.
Who haven't heard about PWC?
No hands.
They are a tax
consultancy company.
Traditionally, they
offer people as a service
to do tax auditing
and accounting.
Today, they're a
technology company.
They had access to
huge data patrons.
Now, they use those
data patrons--
they're using ML-- they built
a cash flow ML API that they're
providing to the
enterprises using
which enterprises can able
to optimize their cash flows.
From a traditional
services company,
they grown into a technology
company offering the ML
based on the existing data
as a service through API.
They can able to
do it 30% faster.
They can able to reduce their
[INAUDIBLE] by a dime by 20%.
Apigee helped them.
It's just not about Apigee.
They're using Google Cloud.
They're using machine learning
to analyze that cash flow data.
They're using Google
App Engine that
talks to the back end system
through Apigee API management
platform.
AccuWeather, anyone
heard about them?
Today, you go to Google search,
search for weather in Jakarta.
One of the first results
that you see in AccuWeather.
They're not only just exposing
the weather information
in their mobile app,
or in their website.
They're exposed
to media channels.
They're exposed to
various third party apps.
They use Apigee developer
portal to publish their API
documentation to
onboard their partners.
They were able to get 24,000
developers into their platform
who are building applications
for them, integrating
with different businesses.
These 24,000 developers
built 11,000 applications
for AccuWeather.
They get today 35 million
API calls every day.
Each API call is bringing
dollars to AccuWeather.
How?
They're monetizing their
APIs, just like Google Maps.
How does Google Maps get money?
Through Google Maps' API.
When Go-Jek calls
Google Maps' API
to find the distance between two
points, Google charges Go-Jek.
Similarly, can your
company do that?
Can your company expose the
APIs and make money out of APIs?
Apigee makes it possible.
Interesting story
about Magazine Luiza.
Just like Bukalapak, an
e-commerce player in Indonesia,
but they're a little
bit different.
They haven't came from
technology background.
Magazine Luiza is a brick
and mortar retail store
in the street that you see.
They're not a technology
company a few years ago.
Their stock was dropping because
of the e-commerce competition.
Now, they are able to
successfully fend off
Amazon in one of the fastest
growing Brazilian markets.
They are the biggest e-commerce
player in Brazil today.
How they can able to do it?
APIs.
They started with
35,000 SKU products.
Today, they have 1.5
million SKU products.
2,000 merchants are
selling their products
on Magazine Luiza platform.
It's just not about that.
The e-commerce platform
that they built,
they're exposing the
entire platform as an API
so that the merchants can have
their own store, online store.
They were able to successfully
connect the demand supply
chain.
They partnered with three banks.
They're using
banks payment APIs.
They partnered with
telcos where they're
leveraging telco services--
through APIs, again.
Their stock has skyrocketed
13,000% in the last few years.
A traditional company.
A traditional brick and
mortar retail chain.
Had no presence online
a few years back.
They were able to
do it and expose
their services, their
API, their products, just
not only on their website, to
Facebook, to mobile, to phone.
You can make a phone
call and purchase
a product powered by API.
So what are the capabilities
these companies are leveraging?
What Apigee platform
provides for you?
So let's take a look
at the technology
stack of Apigee platform.
So visiting between your clients
and your back-end systems.
Your back-end systems
can be legacy.
can be microservices.
Your clients can be new kind of
applications like Google Home.
Or you want to onboard your
partners into your ecosystem,
just like Google does it today.
How different people
consume Google APIs,
can you do the same?
Traditionally, people think that
API management is API Gateway.
Let me have API gateway in
front of my back-end systems.
Let me expose my APIs.
My job is done.
That's what IT teams
are thinking about it.
But that's not solving the
actual business problem.
The business problem
is this slide.
How do I package
my APIs differently
for different teams?
How can I expose my APIs
to different partners?
Can I be able to make
money out of APIs?
Can I build a new app
where my customers
can able to talk to my
business through Google Home?
For example, a credit reporting
agency in the US, Experian.
They're Apigee customer.
Today, US customers can
talk to Google Home,
get to know what is their
credit score, powered by APIs.
Security is enforced by Apigee
or GAPM management platform.
Mediation, talking
to [INAUDIBLE]
is done by Apigee or
[? GAPM ?] management platform.
So what do we offer?
Primarily, four categories.
API runtime, which
includes gateway.
How many of you heard about STO?
Hands?
STO is the next big wave that
is coming to the industry,
just like kubernetes.
That's a platform
to manage, secure,
connect to your microservices.
Every microservice has an API.
How do you publish
API documentation?
How do you enforce security
like [? AWT? ?] Apigee
helps you do that.
The second is mediation engine.
As an enterprise, you
have different systems,
built different periods of
time, different security models.
It's not easy to expose them.
Almost all the data is
sitting inside the Great Walls
of China called firewalls.
How do you expose
them to your partners?
Can you transform existing
legacy [INAUDIBLE] services
to new JSON services?
So Apigee helps you
do the mediation.
Can you talk to the Vision API?
Can you take your data, combine
it, make it as a new API?
Can you do orchestration?
Apigee platform
helps you do that.
Grid, you build the APIs,
you secure the APIs.
You are exposing it.
Your CTO would like to
understand which partner
is bringing more traffic
to me, which services
are they accessing, where do
I need to invest next quarter.
Can your dev ops team find out
before even an app goes down?
Apigee provides
analytics and intelligent
contextual monitoring
for your APIs.
And importantly,
developer ecosystem.
Today, there is a
developer.google.com
where you can find
Vision API, where
you can find speech-to-text API,
where you can find Google Maps
API, a whole world for your
company, for your services.
Don't you want to have
a developer portal
where you want to onboard your
partners without any friction?
Don't you want to
monetize your APIs
and publish the API packages
in the developer portal
where your partners can buy
and bring revenue to you?
We provide developer
portal where
you can publish
API documentation,
onboard developers, publish APIs
as a product that has a price
tag associated
with it so that you
can able to make money directly
from the developer portal.
What are we doing
inside the Google Cloud?
We are part of Google Cloud.
You are using Google Cloud.
You are using Google
Cloud Machine Learning.
You are building your back-end
systems in Google Cloud.
Now you want to expose
them to your Google Home
hub, or your partner.
We help you connect
to different systems.
We help you secure
your APIs and services
using the same security
that Google uses, [? AWT. ?]
We scale to billions
of API calls.
On an average day,
Apigee handles
more than 3 billion
requests on Cloud
with finance of availability.
And we provide the
connectors directly
to talk to all the
existing Google features.
So that-- let's say
you are using big data,
you are doing some
analysis, now you
want to connect
that to Google Home
without writing a
single line of code.
We help you do that.
The technology is great.
You have seen the
stories, but you
need a strategy to drive
your API program to convince
everyone in the company.
Just like you are
going to an adventure,
you need a tool
like compass, right?
Which can help you point
into the right direction.
We built a tool that
will help you do that.
What does this tool will do?
Your CEO is thinking
about network effects.
Your CEO is thinking about
onboarding new partners.
digital transformation.
Your CTO is thinking
about modernization,
moving from [INAUDIBLE] to
microservices using the latest
greatest technologies.
But there is an operational gap.
How do we bring
everyone on board?
What are the key
performance indicators?
So using Apigee tool,
you can able to find
actionable results that can
help you in your API program.
Again, it will set
a baseline, it'll
give you a digital score,
where does your company
stands in the digital
transformation,
and the steps that can help
you put in the right direction.
So it gives it three
dimensions, vision.
Are you thinking
about transformation,
business transformation,
or IT modernization?
What is your
eco-system strategy?
Do you want to go
integrate with other people
in other ecosystems?
Are you thinking APIs
just as an integration
between your mobile app,
website, to the back-end?
Or are you thinking of
the strategic products
that you can take into
different business teams?
Alignment, who is
leading your API program
from where it is coming.
Is it the IT team?
Is it the business team?
How are you measuring the
impact of API program?
Is it a number of API calls?
Is it the partner
onboarding time?
Is it the number of partners you
want on board to your platform?
Just like AccuWeather
who onboarded
24,000 developers and
hundreds of companies
into their platform.
Great you have a
vision and alignment.
What about the execution?
Do you have the right team?
And can your developers access
your APIs within five minutes?
So using this tool, you can
find actionable results that
will help your API program.
Let's understand directly from
the leading bank in the region
how they're becoming
a technology company.
It's a privilege to
work with Bank BRI.
Let me invite
[INAUDIBLE] Rheza Satria,
who's the head of Digital Center
of Excellence in BRI Bank.
Please give him a big
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
RHEZA SATRIA: Thank you.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Thank you for having me here.
Today I'm going to talk about
digital initiative in Bank BRI.
That is that we have been
really working hard in 2018.
And if you don't know about
BRI, I will let you know.
We are the biggest--
one of the biggest
bank in Indonesia.
Our market cap is about
$34 billion US dollars.
That is just in February 2018.
And our assets is around $83
billion in just last year.
And then our net profit
last year, as you know it,
is around $2 billion.
And not only that we have a lot
of branches across Indonesia,
starting from Sabang to
Merauke from West Indonesia
to East Indonesia.
If you call it, it will
be around 10,000 branches.
And not only that, we also
have our mobile agent.
The mobile agent
is very, very huge.
We are also, I think,
[INAUDIBLE] Go-Jek
of doing the mobile agents.
We have around 29,000
people for mobile agents.
And you know that our ATM is
also the biggest in Indonesia.
It's around 24,000 ATMs.
Having said that, we
are now facing a great
in rising of fintech in
the financial industry.
As you know, there have
been market dips [INAUDIBLE]
in the financial industry,
especially for the banks.
It really impacts us.
I don't consider this--
it's not impacting us,
but it is impacting
us indirectly.
I've been looking
for the four areas.
It is the payment lending
and the [INAUDIBLE] and also
the personal finance.
If you notice that today is
what you try to lend the money
is maybe not for the bank,
but you get the money
from the fintech.
Let's say that from
a [INAUDIBLE],, maybe
from [INAUDIBLE].
Why?
Because it's really fast
to get the money from them
in just a matter of days.
But in combination
with us, you may
need to fill out the paperwork,
that is endless time.
And let-- it will take maybe
a month, or maybe two months,
but after that, you see that
is a long way process if you
try to get maybe a
[INAUDIBLE],, or a business
without [INAUDIBLE].
And for the payment perspective,
in Indonesia we do have Go-Jek.
You know that [INAUDIBLE] is
actually a challenge for us
because they starting
doing the payment industry.
We just taking our
[INAUDIBLE] effectively.
And also, you know that
we have other competitors
like [INAUDIBLE] and maybe
[INAUDIBLE] payment gateway.
And also for the
personal finance,
as you know it,
that you have-- we
have actually competitors like
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]..
But we need to work
with those competitors
in the end, especially when
considering the new technology
developments in AI, big data,
and blockchain, and even the
cloud itself.
So BRI is actually
doing the digitization,
starting from the
legacy of this paper,
and also, it's a
very complex process,
and it's a long process.
And now, in 2018, we have
two products in internal BRI.
First is MyBRI and the second
is BRI Spot, or BRISpot.
MyBRI is to help our agents
in the fields to operate
with a [? motet, ?] while
B Spot is for microlending.
But what are the resources?
The resources that we--
we see that they are 30% to
40% increase in the [INAUDIBLE]
[? productivity. ?] And
80% motets for microloans
with less than
two days approval.
So this is-- how do we actually
either get with the partners
that we need to deal
with every one of them.
It's different project, or
business model for one of them.
As you know that, we have
the open API in the middle,
and we have [INAUDIBLE]
like our legacy system
that connects to the
open API and also
the third party
developers, or maybe
the fintech developers and
the mobile web applications.
And by the said,
the [INAUDIBLE] is
that we can [INAUDIBLE]
[? product ?] offering.
We just-- we also can
monetize our own API.
And with Epigee,
we can see that--
as [INAUDIBLE] was saying--
inside BRI.
So let's say the customers
will connect to the phone
apps of [INAUDIBLE],, and
any other marketplaces,
and in the middle you
see that it will--
they will connect with
Epigee, or BRI API.
And then, in the
back-end, the Bank BRI,
we actually-- we
can actually expose
the [INAUDIBLE] and
maybe [INAUDIBLE]
or [INAUDIBLE] all
credit scoring.
So as a conclusion,
we can actually
see that this is
much more easier
to collaborate with third
party, or with our partners
compared with using the Apigee.
So let's talk about
the BRILink Agen,
because this is
very special to us.
This is-- it will help out
digital transformation.
And especially,
considering that there
are a lot of Agen BRILink
across the country.
So how do we actually
find the best Agen BRILink
for our specific customers?
That's why I think
we can find it--
also, we can consume the
Google Map API to actually find
the nearest Agen BRILink at
certain cities, something
like that.
I think, for
conclusion, years ago,
we considered ourself
just like a [INAUDIBLE]..
We had a lot of regulations.
As you know that,
we are [INAUDIBLE]..
And I think today we can
consider ourselves as a bank,
as an ID company
with a bank license.
And there are two
quotes for me that
is taken from Brad King
and Michael [INAUDIBLE],,
banking is no longer
somewhere you go.
It's something you do.
And we see ourselves
as a technology company
with a bank license.
I think that's it for me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ANIL SAGAR: Thank you.
So you heard about the customer
story of BRI Bank, right?
You heard about how
a traditional bank is
becoming a technology company.
So we would like to
open up for questions.
If you have any,
happy to answer them.
Any questions in the audience?
Again, you can learn more
about Apigee in Apigee.com.
And keep us posted.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]